[Music]
movie four shadows how slow it's gonna
feel Timon and Pumba are both in the
film but sadly don't share any screen
time together you guys want jokes about
scrotum faces well here you go mom Angie
tells me you the writer refers to the
uncle is mama Chi but earlier was
calling him Francis until PI said I call
him mama he pretty presumptuous if you
ask me man
he's PI's mama G not your mama G is it
cool to do imitations of an Indian right
to an indians face I don't think that's
cool man
like if PI and Mama G were black would
you do a black man's voice this is the
first little kid in history to actually
be interested in those comic books that
religions put out to try and seem hip
say great story but that kids got
horrible cavities pi drinks holy water
but his soul doesn't start burning
discount Mandy Patinkin everybody's name
in this movie has a cutesy backstory but
the names got switched on the Piplup
it's been 20 years in Jurassic park's
real-world effects are still better than
today's oscar-winning computer effects
in unrelated news Jurassic Park 3d at a
theater near you only Tigers know the
key to fitting large goats through
narrow cage bars movie reinforces the
stereotype that stalking women makes
them attracted to you which I can tell
you from personal experience is
definitely not true
wait a minute I thought all teenage
Indian love matches occurred through a
lucky game of Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire I think you set the stage so
far we have an Indian boy named after a
French swimming pool on a Japanese ship
full of animals heading to Canada yeah
and all the boring stuff about the
girlfriend and the kid with the universe
in his mouth they'll call this journey
we brought a zoo why don't they I was
sleeping with a lights on this is
jackass and this is pissing on Davy
Jones face they made the sim some to be
unsinkable
but hubris was the flaw they didn't
account for movie teases shark several
times but never has the balls to go for
it
if you were really sorry to throw
yourself down there after an orangutan
riding a pile of bananas that somehow
feels racist just remind yourself
there's a tiger under this tarp the
whole time who apparently doesn't notice
any of the going on and also a hyena as
well apparently which was totally cool
hanging out down there with a target and
also Pi goes digging around under there
for supplies and never sees a fully
grown tiger in there lindsay lohan joke
I wish I could tell you the Heian had to
meet the zebra but being shipwrecked is
no fairytale world you're gonna need a
bigger boat ah tarp the natural enemy of
the tiger he's playing dead because
Tigers don't eat dead things except for
that zebra over there
now I'm no water scientist or anything
but I have it on good authority the
ocean is pretty much never mirror still
like this but I do think it's a cool
shot dude that is the same tarp you use
as your drinking water collection device
no boat and then a boat why would you CG
the boat pi is such a nerd he doesn't
know the real lyrics to 99 bottles of
beer do ocean fish just go to the
surface and swim directly into Nets
movie takes a few seconds to turn into
Tim Burton's Life of Pi dude bad idea
don't you know that's exactly the method
used to draw giant whales to the surface
hunga can change everything you ever
thought you knew about this movie is
essentially a narrated flashback of a
narrated flashback Wow taming a tiger
turns out to be much simpler than anyone
ever realized t-rex doesn't want to be
fed he wants to hunt this is where the
movie really started to poke the shark
wow that boat is a real asshole Jesus is
the most densely populated part of the
middle of the ocean is he on the EAC
[Music]
my father once told me that stars were
the kings of the past
[Music]
now me I was scared Lieutenant Dan he
was mad man your cats ain't scared oh
you're a big bad tiger and you're eating
my brother I'm cool I'm just gonna chill
so we do prefer wait a minute is this
like inception we're nothing we saw was
real you mean they could literally have
done anything in this movie and it would
all have been okay there's no sins
that's perhaps the worst sin of all I
didn't know you had a way you spent all
day with this guy mostly in his home and
you never noticed any signs that he was
married with children like photos or
toys
[Music]
good feelings gone